How agents broke
infrastructure. Particularly, we're
going to focus on the compute layer
today. My name is Evan Bole, the founder
and CEO in Genisx. I was an early
employee of Palumi and I've spent my
entire career working on cloud and
developer
tools. Typo warning. In the spirit of
embracing AI for this talk, all diagrams
are AI generated, but 40 still has some
spelling issues. So, thank you for your
patience. We all know this journey. We
start off as AI engineers with a simple
prompt and a couple of tool calls and
typically this is enough to raise our
$10 million seed round. But from there,
when rubber meets the road, we end up
building workflows, right? We take that
fully non-deterministic code and make as
much of it deterministic as possible.
That might mean chaining a couple of
very specific tailored prompts together
that we've written eval
uh and more carefully controlling the
context. This takes the runtime of our
workflows from 30 seconds to a couple of
minutes. But eventually we all end up
becoming data engineers because the most
challenging part of the problem is
getting the right context into the
prompts. And that means that we might
have to crawl a user's inbox, ingest
code from GitHub or many other artifacts
that require lots and lots of LM
processing.
But our assumptions around infra have
changed. In web 2.0, you would build a
simple web service where you'd make an
API request, maybe talk to a database to
fetch some data, and return all that
back in a few tens of milliseconds. In
AI applications, our P1 is a couple of
seconds at best, and that's only if
you're using a fast model or if you hit
a prompt cache. In the previous era of
infrastructure, if you had a request
that took a couple of seconds, your on
call was getting paged. Um, and so the
infrastructure that was designed for the
last 10 years of the web is not really
designed for the applications that we're
building
today. LM applications are really built
on shoddy uh foundations. It's really
hard to build reliable apps today. And
if you're like us and you run a tight
ship, you might have a Slack channel
that looks like this where you subscribe
to, you know, issues and outages from
your dependencies. But luckily, this one
only lasts, you know, an hour. By 10
p.m., it's
resolved. But, oh, at 1:20 a.m. we're
back at it. And 4:00 a.m. it's still
going on. But surely, you know, Chat GPT
and OpenAI have have better
availability, right? Well, I wouldn't
really trust this 99.9% uptime number.
And no, it's not lots of yellow and red
in this graph. But maybe we could have
failed over to, you know, Gemini during
this time period. Nope, we have an
outage during the exact same time
period. And even if you don't hit an
outage, you still have rate limits to
contend with. A lot of these traffic
patterns are going to be extremely
bursty as you batch process documents
from a user or you onboard new
customers. And not everybody has tier
five rate limits that require spending
thousands of dollars just to get to that
point that you can start experimenting
with high levels of
traffic. So we start off nice and happy
with our prototype. Maybe we built
something on top of the next.js chatbot
template. That's easy, right? But as our
workflows start running for minutes and
hours, us full stack AI engineers
accidentally become data
engineers. So how do people solve this
today? You know there this used to be
something that was rather niche
longunning workflows data engineering.
So there is an existing set of tools.
People build these Rub Goldberg machines
on top of cues like SQS. They might use
batch processing data engineering tools
like Airflow or durable execution
engines like Temporal. But me
personally, I'm a Typescript developer.
I'm a full stack engineer. And frankly,
I don't want to use anything that was
designed by a Java engineer. No offense.
I'd much rather use serverless. What
about existing serverless providers?
They aren't really well suited for these
kinds of longrunning workflows. Uh most
of them time out after 5 minutes and
some of them even limit outgoing HTTP
requests and for all of them they don't
really have native streaming support.
Streaming is something that you have to
bolt on at the application layer and not
something that's a native part of the
infrastructure that you're building on
top of. something that's really
important when you're building an
application that might run for multiple
minutes. Users might refresh the page.
So you want
resumability. And so let's look at some
of these common product experiences.
We're going to look at both onboarding
where we might ingest a bunch of data
from the user with an LLM upfront and
then also a product experience where
we're going to run an agent that's going
to take multiple minutes and we have to
keep the user engaged during that time
period. So during this onboarding
experience, the user puts in their URL,
right? Right? And we use a single LM
call to grab some information from that
web page and then detect all the pages
that we're going to scrape. Right? And
now we've kicked off that scraping job
in the background and it's going to take
multiple minutes uh and we're going to
be making hundreds of LLM calls to
extract content from those web pages and
enrich them. And we want the user to be
able to start using the product right
away. So this ingestion can take, you
know, a varying amount of time, but we
want users to use the app immediately.
If we wait 10 minutes, that means we're
going to have increased fall-off in the
funnel. So, we have to run this in the
background, right? And we want to show
users the status of this ingestion as
they're using the product. We want them
to know, hey, as time goes on, we're
going to enrich more data and your
experience is going to get
better. Next, this is an example of
building a content generation app,
right? We're going to write a blog post
uh about building high performance web
apps with Versell and Nex.js. And this
agent, we tell the user up front, sit
back and relax. This is going to take a
couple of minutes. And on the right,
we're showing them all of the different
steps, right? We're running research.
We're writing an
outline. And we're writing each section
step by step. Since this takes multiple
minutes, it's really important that if
the user leaves the page or navigates
away that they don't lose this context,
right? And so that workflow that we
built when working on a previous product
took 3 to four minutes. And we really
felt a lot of friction experimenting
with longer workflows. Like we were
deterred from making our workflows
longer than five plus minutes because
that meant that we would have to make
deep infra changes due to limitations
from our serverless provider. Eventually
we did rip it out and it was a bunch of
work but it took us much longer than we
should have to run those experiments uh
because of the amount of work that was
required to migrate off of you know our
easytouse serverless offering.
Also, we need to stream both the final
content as well as the intermediate
status. And if the user refreshes the
page and comes back, we want them to see
that same thing, just like you get with
deep research, right? And if there's an
intermediate error, users are going to
be way more frustrated if it takes them
5 minutes to get back to that same point
uh versus if it's just, you know, a
simple web page that you have to refresh
or a form that you have to resubmit.
So we built a lot to make this easy in
our core product uh when we were working
on you know agentic workflows uh and we
ended up turning a lot of this into an
open source
library. So we built a simple component
model that's infra in infrastructure
aware right uh the the framework itself
is very aware of the infrastructure it's
running on and the infrastructure is
aware of the framework and that's so
that we can provide things like
resumable streams for intermediate
status uh and final output and we call
this a bit of an anti-framework. It's
unopinionated and focused on building
blocks. uh it's it takes inspiration
from React's component model and applies
it to the back end because we know that
abstraction is bad when building agents.
You don't want to abstract. You want to
share, you want to compose, you want to
reuse code. So we have components that
are reusable, item potent, independently
testable steps and then workflows that
are collections of components that run
together. So this is a simple component
that uses a wrapped version of the
OpenAI SDK. It's wrapped so that we can
get a bunch of other tooling for retries
and tracing and things like that, but
it's the same exact OpenAI surface area
that you would expect. We give you full
access to the model. So, it's just a
prompt, a little bit of context that's
inject ingested and it returns a
response. So, a simple function that
takes in some prompts and returns some
output and it can be independently run
or tested. We can also combine it
together into what we call a workflow.
This workflow fetches the front page of
Hacker News, analyzes those posts,
generates reports, writes a tweet, and
then edits the
report. And with this, every single
step, we're going to get a retry
boundary, an error boundary off each
component. And we're going to get traces
both at the top level of the workflow,
but also all of the components that run
within it. Each workflow can be turned
into a set of REST APIs automatically by
the framework that support synchronous
invocation as well as asynchronous
invocation and the relevant API so that
we can retrieve the intermediate stream
and the final output stream if
needed. When we run this workflow, we
see that we get a trace. This trace
shows us all of the nested components
that run inside the workflow, including
all the tokens, all the details on the
OpenAI call, user messages, system
messages. So, it makes it super easy to
debug. And we have built-in retries.
Every component has a fluent API hung
off of it that allows you to configure a
component with things like retries and a
cache. So if I have one component that's
particularly problematic, I can add an
exponential retry policy uh with and and
configure the number of retries that
run. And so this all gets deployed to a
serverless platform that we built that's
tailor made for longunning workflows and
building agentic UIs uh for processes
that run in the background. So we have
an API layer and a compute layer that
are completely separate. And this is
really important for a lot of reasons.
The API the API layer invokes the
compute layer and passes it in a reddish
stream ID. That's the last time that the
API layer is going to have to talk to
the compute layer. The rest of it is
going to happen via communication with
this reddest stream. Status is going to
come from the reddest stream. The output
is going to come from the reddest
stream. And as the sandbox program
executes, it's going to emit heartbeats
so that the background processes within
the system can monitor and make sure
that a workflow runs to completion and
doesn't die or doesn't crash. And if it
does, we can automatically restart it or
notify the
user. So key architectural points of
this is this separation between the API
and the compute layer. It allows us to
scale things independently, scale the
API layer independent of the compute
layer. It also allows us to plug that
compute layer. So we can provide uh a
compute layer by default on top of ECS,
but we can allow users to bring their
own compute layer as well since it's
completely stateless and just talks to
the API layer and the reddest streams to
store
output. All that API goes to the Reddus
stream both for sync and async workflows
which means that we get resumability,
right? The API layer only reads from the
reddest stream, not the compute layer
directly. So that means that we can
build UIs that allow users to refresh
the page, navigate away, transparently
handle errors, uh, and they still get
the full history of status messages and
all of the output. Um, something that
you wouldn't get from a typical
serverless like infra
platform. Like we said, key point here
is being able to refresh the page,
resume directly from the Reddus stream,
and get all of your intermediate status
messages. none of the work is lost if
the new user navigates away or if the
web browser terminates the connection to
the API
server. So things and lessons to
consider when you're building your own
infrastructure for agentic workflows.
Always start simple. You're not going to
write a workflow that runs for an hour
on day one. So don't build for it. But
do plan for a future that's longunning.
In my opinion, this is where agents are
going. And I think that we can see this
with all of the recent coding agents
that have come around experiences like
deep research. Like the future is giving
your agent instructions and letting it
go off and do work for you and
communicate with you when you need it.
And to make that happen, think about
keeping your compute and API plane
separate and lean on Reddit streams for
resumability. Make it easy to you for
users to navigate away from the page,
not lose progress and handle errors
transparently.
All this is also to say you got to take
care when deploying. If you're going to
let your workflows run for 60 minutes,
you have to be very very careful about
how you drain workers and how you uh do
kind of a blue green deployment pattern.
And overall, the devil is really in the
details. Easy to get started, but very
hard to get this right.
Now, it's really, really fun to build
all of this infrastructure yourself, but
if you don't want to build it yourself,
I'd encourage you to check out GenSx on
GitHub where we've implemented a lot of
this for you. Again, my name is Evan.
Thanks for having me at this talk. Uh,
and happy building.